the Joe Rogan experience I had a dream
that I was wait for the Joe Rogan
podcast and I also had a dream that Brad
Pitt and I were dating and I was in fact
late as we've talked about so I can't
[Music]
nice ladies and good music I got one for
you I did it was incredible how how
weird was the violence oh god it was
tough I watched it with my parents and
what's what was ironic is they knew who
all the characters were like my dad said
oh I bet that's text I'll bet because
those were real people still are some of
them and you know that was kind of
chilling to me to think about the fact
that they knew by name who these Charlie
Manson heads were by watching this move
because you know way before my time so
what's super super popular story and the
other part about it is like those people
that killed those folks you know how the
story turned down right so you're
expecting yeah I loved a happier ending
it's nice it's like inglorious basterds
- they're just other Brad Pitt movie and
like just plugging this one or what he
knows he's a wizard he's he's the last
guy allowed to make a movie like that
yeah when I said that the violence was
shocking I don't mean necessarily that
it's bad I'm not saying that I'm saying
shocking that in a movie in 2020 you
could have a dude smash some girl's head
yeah exactly I mean this is wild that's
pretty grandfathered in I think
Tarantino's grandfathered in right cuz
everybody has always known him for
having the wildest craziest [ __ ] see
from pulp fiction yeah straight on his
whole career like tiny to be expected
yeah yeah the [ __ ] uma Thurman with
the the injection and the horror I mean
so many of his movies classic Halloween
costume nobody goes deeper than
Tarantino but the thing is that he can
still do a super ultra violent movie and
people consider it great art mm-hmm and
I think that's getting harder and harder
to
right I think I think he's sort of like
everybody knows that's a Tarantino movie
you're gonna need to see some madness
right but I think of a new person tried
to do it they would hit more woke
reaction more people like are we really
celebrating a scene where a guy smashes
a woman's a head into pulp he does a
good job of like good like getting up
the good guy to win oh yeah so and we
all want that badly so you know if
anything like he's got a formula that
continues to work yeah I want to see the
bad guys get the [ __ ] kicked out of them
that's it's there's justice yeah it's
[ __ ] great it's fun entertainment you
know but there's a sort of resistance to
certain narratives and and certain kind
of scenes certain kinds of depictions of
violence no you shouldn't even have it
for entertainment sake mm-hmm you know
god damn it's so nice having someone
like him around yeah I would love to I
met him at the Comedy Store he's super
nice cool but he makes madness you know
you leave a Tarantino movie like what
the [ __ ]
pretty soon Joe you're gonna be in the
next Tarantino movie no keep talking
like this I'm just appreciative that's
great I'm with you that's why I'm
appreciative of music to have no idea
what's going on
[Applause]